as podcast has bad words hello everybody
welcome to the minimalist podcast where
we discuss what it means to live a
meaningful life with less my name is
joshua fields Millburn and i am ryan
nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist welcome to episode 135 today
we're gonna talk about acquaintances
talking about friendships relating
relationships partnerships intimate
relationships people things wait maybe
some things yeah man acquaintances Ryan
you know today I was a regular podcast
right here this is where all the
advertisements would start that's right
man we could talk about if you're a if
your company and you're looking to hire
people when you talk about if your
underwear or writing up your ass crack
too much oh my god how about yesterday
was that we're recording this the day
after Memorial Day Ryan mm-hmm how was
your Memorial Day well I I spent it one
the true way that it was meant to be
spent mattress shopping mmm I got 15%
off yesterday you know you could have
got a hundred percent off if he didn't
buy it
Ryan you know the memory foam never
forgets so today we're we don't have any
advertisers because well we don't do
advertisements so we might as well dive
right into today's questions what do you
say Ryan let's do a man's get into these
voicemails who's our first one from
Jordan Jordan and Parker Parker Colorado
where is Parker do you know I have to
google that it's in Colorado Iowa
Parker's asking this question I'm going
to Google where Parker Colorado is his
name is Jordan
go ahead Jordan did you find it was a
curve or struggle to attract the people
who fit your same ideals or lifestyle
that you two have adopted so I guess
what I met Ryan is her name is Jordan
yeah you know Jordan is not just a male
name Josh apparently neither is Parker
all right so so let's talk about
struggles the struggle to attract people
to who share this lifestyle and so the
first thing I thought about Ryan is our
first book minimalism live a meaningful
life
the
chapter in there is a chapter about
relationships and I printed out a couple
pages from it page 52 and 53 and I just
wanted to read over a little bit here so
going from like a your past life or your
previous self to a new self a new and
improved self I know that my problem was
for the longest time and and tell me if
you relate to this I I tried to sort of
well it was the opposite of what she
talked about I tried to fit my lifestyle
around other people's expectations and
so I tried to be the person I thought
everyone wanted me to be but of course
different people wanted me to be a
different person so I was like Stretch
Armstrong with my my values and beliefs
and for this person I was trying to be
this person and for that person I was
trying to be this person and and for
another person I was trying to be
someone else but along the way I wasn't
being myself at all yeah especially as
an introvert man that's that's got to be
draining in yes especially and the weird
thing is I didn't realize I was an
introvert I just thought that like I was
there was something wrong with me
because it's like well this person would
be like this I better I better adjust
myself a little bit now I think you can
be fluent in multiple dialects and I
think you can coexist among different
types of people and still be your
authentic self you can still be you it's
just like if you know Spanish and you're
hanging around a bunch of people who
speak Spanish it is polite to speak
Spanish it's gonna be really rude if
you're around those people and you
pretend to speak Spanish though and you
don't know a word a single word of
Spanish you're just gonna be a jerk
right yeah so I didn't realize at the
time but I was accidentally being a jerk
around these people because I was trying
to conform to what their expectations
were and so this is a little excerpt
from minimalism live a meaningful life
the the third chapter here on
relationships this subsection here is
called reflecting on past relationships
the past is not equal to future living
in the past is tantamount to driving
using only the rearview mirror
eventually you will crash crash if you
don't know what's going on in front of
you because of this your past
relationships aren't necessarily
indicative of your future relationships
and this is good news much of the time
you don't think about why you're
involved in a particular relationship
you just ended up there and you accept
that this is where you are even when the
relationship makes you unhappy that was
something to happen to me all the time
like well this is we're neighbours we're
coworkers were whatever we just happened
we collided into each other so all of a
sudden this is some sort of relationship
this is an acquaintance of mine Yeah
right and I'm gonna drag this
relationship in perpetuity you can learn
from your past relationships though the
good times tell you what went well and
give you a strategy by which you can
model your future and the bad times help
you identify how things went wrong and
give you and give you clues and social
cues by which you can avoid bad
relationships in the future everything
is clearer in retrospect there are three
ways to create better relationships and
so III think about I think about this
with respect to Jordan's question here
the first thing you can do is you can
find new relationships you've heard me
say a million times before you can't
change the people around you but you can
change the people around you so instead
of me trying to conform to everyone else
or try to get them to conform to me how
about attracting people who have similar
values similar interests and there are a
few things I think about there when I
think about values I also think about do
we share similar curiosities or do we
share a similar well geographies even
something that is important if we want
to spend a lot of time together but it's
not it's not necessary as well we can
talk about that and also do we are we
willing to share similar discomforts hmm
you and I signed up for the West
Hollywood dodgeball rec league recently
dude yeah I I'm so looking forward to
that is gonna be so much fun because
honestly I wanted to put a volleyball
team together uh-huh but no one I know
well a likes to play volleyball right or
can play volleyball and this is like the
perfect substitute for a volleyball team
well and so what we're doing is me you
backs Mariah we try to convince podcast
he wasn't having any of it and Matt D
Avella and his partner Natalie so we're
all going to join this West Hollywood
dodgeball team and a rec league and the
reason I want to it in fact Beck's
Kennedy said this is the most surprising
development of the entire year for me
that Josh you want to go out and do this
and for me it's like it's because it
makes me uncomfortable to do it like
being around that many people doing
something new and being willing to sort
of dive into a discomfort together is a
way that people grow our doctor dr.
green over Metro MD one of the things he
talks about I will go to the soul cycle
together another thing it's absolutely
an uncomfortable day my good you went
last week it was the last week yeah a
week before yeah whatever whatever it
was yeah yeah and anyway like going to
that makes you uncomfortable also you
realize that by sort of sweating
together either literally or
figuratively you grow together yeah
you're gonna build better relationships
that way yeah it's like a sort of
kinesthetic learning yeah and I find
that getting uncomfortable together
trying new things together helps you
develop and expand those relationships
and and it's not about bringing other
minimalists into my life
right it's not it's not about it's not
about finding professional organizers to
hang out with yeah which would be fine
but that's not the only people we hang
out with no because you would think that
like you me Leo about Josh Becker
Cortney Carver we would be like the best
of friends all of us hanging out all of
us hanging out drinking coffee talking
about minimalism now and those people
are really good friends in my life
they're able people and and one of the
things we wrote about in minimalism live
a meaningful life are the the three
different types of relationship you have
your primary relationships that the
people you can usually count on on one
hand your close family members maybe a
business partner or really close friends
and then you have secondary
relationships good friends people you
spend a decent amount of time with
people you would prioritize in your life
people you love and care about and you
have the the peripheral relationships
the people on that tertiary tier if you
think about these as
concentric circles and my problem for
the longest time is I was spending 90%
of my time with the people on that that
outer layer and so I forsook the people
and the two closest circles because I'm
like I'll they'll understand I'm so
focused on my career and spending time
with networking buddies and co-workers
and executives and the sad part is is
sometimes they actually do understand ah
you know what I'm saying yeah sometimes
they will like I remember I showed up to
family get-togethers and you know the
few times I'd see him each year I was
always like oh there is our corporate
success the guy in the family who's
working really hard and it's okay that
he can't see us because we know he's out
there making money we know he's out
there you know getting promoted and
climbing the ladder it's like that's I
think it's even worse sometimes when
people give us permission to ignore them
yeah and yeah that's that's a pretty
dangerous slope yeah I think so because
eventually they're gonna stop giving
them permission they're gonna feel like
you are neglecting them yeah right yeah
and I know that's true like I'll
understand for a while but over time
it's gonna feel like oh I'm being taken
advantage of ever every relationship
that we're in I wrote about this and
everything that remains is sort of this
this us box and you give what you can
you take what you need from a
relationship but if you're just taking
taking taking taking and not giving what
you can well then you're a parasite yeah
and and I think sometimes what happens
is because we get so me focused so
career focus so accomplishment focus we
start to take more than we're giving and
when we do that the relationship suffers
and ultimately the relationship suffers
I suffer too right even though I was the
one the collecting it I'm gonna end up
suffering in the long run as well
because I'm not giving what I need to
give to that you know if you have a
plant in your house you're never
watering it and then all of a sudden it
dies it doesn't feel good about that
I mean as much as it can feel right but
you don't feel good about either you've
got a dead plant now you have to like
try to nourish or get rid of and getting
rid of it isn't what you want it that's
not why you got it in the first place
right and so when I when I when I think
about about what Jordan is is going
through here is it a big struggle
and I would say yeah it's definitely
going to be a big struggle bringing
people in your life but it's not about
do we own the same things it can be we
have the same hobbies we have the same
interest but I think ultimately it comes
down to we have the same values and so
the only two questions I think I would
ask Jordan here is why would people want
to spend time with you
and so think about that right what what
your ideal friends look like your ideal
acquaintances your ideal co-workers your
ideal intimate relationship what does
that ideal person look like and then
what type of person would attract that
person and if you ask that then you can
help better shape the person that you
want to become to attract those people
yeah yeah for me Jordan it was it wasn't
that difficult really to to attract
people and I'll tell you why I am an
extrovert so for me I love throwing
myself like the dodgeball is not very
uncomfortable for me like that is
something that I am totally looking
forward to throwing myself into I threw
myself into acting in a play I threw
myself into actually was a couple plays
I acted in doing some you know volunteer
work whatever it was I went out of my
way to do things in the community that
that I knew I would have opportunities
to meet other people in the community
and I didn't meet friends you know right
away at first they became acquaintances
I think like Rebecca Schaeffer is a
great example she was the director of
that that play I was in and her and I
were really good acquaintances and I
don't know when you know it switched to
us being really really good friends
right but after a time of of spending
you know working on that play
she had a cabaret that Mariah and I
would go up and we would we would
support her in the cabaret it was really
fun to watch it was fun to support our
friend or I guess maybe our acquaintance
at the time but eventually after me and
Mariah we went out of our way
to to do the same things that rebecca
did not because we were just trying to
be a Rebecca's friend but it's she
always liked to do things we did or she
was producing shows that that we really
liked to see but yes after spending
enough time we were able to become
really close friends I mean she's
staying at my house right now
and in my spare bedroom so so yeah it's
for me it's not difficult because I go
out of my way to throw myself into
different things into the community
where I know I'm going to meet I am
gonna say like-minded people not just
open-minded people but like-minded
people people who are interested in the
same things I am so whether it's a soup
kitchen whether it's being in a play
whether it's adopting a highway whatever
it is find something Jordan that you can
throw yourself into in the community and
you can meet people who have the same
interests I mean of course there's
always meetup comm you can go to and
find different groups that you could
find some like-minded people you can go
on OkCupid do whatever you want but
there are ways to to kind of dive
headfirst into into finding people with
the same interests the same values the
same beliefs yeah in fact I think with
all of that except the beliefs part I
think I think quite often if you want
your relationships to be interesting
you're probably gonna have a lot of
different beliefs like you have
different interests different beliefs
they converge in some places but we have
the same values and then occasionally I
think our our beliefs and our interests
they converge in certain areas but they
also diverge quite a bit as well and I
think that's what makes a relationship
interesting yeah I I think that you and
I are on the same exact page with that I
think that when it comes to beliefs they
do have to be a little bit similar if I
believed in reptile people and I was
constantly pitching you conspiracy
theories that involved reptile people
you probably you probably wouldn't hang
out with me too much yeah you probably
would avoid hanging out with me less
yeah I mean that's that's a mental
illness though okay
I don't know anyone who believes in that
who doesn't have who truly believes in
it doesn't have
a identify I don't have the data to say
one way or the other so I don't know but
but I guess what I'm saying is is that
yeah I absolutely really beliefs are
don't have to be this staple it doesn't
have to be this main this main thing
that unites two people but it is
something that ya can add a little
variety to your relationship but it can
also make the relationship stronger I
mean think about church man that's why
Church works so well yeah it's because
you've got a community of people who
genuinely care about each other they
they are all focused on the same thing
and they all have the same belief that
belief is really really uniting in a lot
of ways I think that even you know folks
like that still you want to have friends
acquaintances in your life that have a
little bit of a varying belief because
yes you don't want to just be stuck in a
bubble you don't wanna be stuck in a box
yeah and I also works if you have nearly
identical beliefs and I think about my
partner Rebecca and I we our beliefs are
nearly identical and so our
personalities and and that tends to work
out it's just that if every relationship
in my life had the same beliefs it'd be
easy to be comfortable to be in a bubble
man yeah I don't feel like I'd grow that
way right totally agree and and so I'm
gonna hide this sorry where we're we're
filming this for the first time I don't
know if this is gonna make it on YouTube
or not but podcast Shawn is I'm just
realizing how filming this adds a
completely different element yeah it's a
dynamic it like makes me feel like I
need to be more animated when I talk so
that way like it looks good for the
camera you have to do that but you see
the footage if you're just listening to
the Brian is essentially doing jumping
jacks without jumping right now but uh
when I think about the relationships I
have and I think that maybe the the
church analogy that you you provided
there was a good one I was talking to TK
Coleman about this and he was on the
podcast on the school podcast we did and
he the thing that he said was hey you
can instead of going out looking for
someone who wants to go to church with
you or finding if I couldn't
I'm gonna go to dodgeball with me guess
what there be a whole bunch of people at
dodgeball who would want to go to
dodgeball whatever and so you can go by
yourself and find other like-minded
people in that scenario it doesn't mean
they're gonna have all the same values
beliefs interest as you but they will
have similar interest to you in that
particular setting and so you can just
show up instead of trying to drag
someone else there who may not be
interested in it and then your leg and
they're roasting over because they're
not enjoying themselves the worst thing
in the world for me is if I take someone
to a concert and I'm constantly watching
them the whole time to see if they're
enjoying the concert instead of just
enjoying the concert it's funny and so I
when I go to a concert with someone it
usually has to be now or it's like I
know they're going to enjoy this
otherwise it's just gonna meet be me
wondering whether or not they enjoy the
concert the entire time yeah you go with
that the the dodgeball example before
you had reached out to me dude I was
looking at volleyball leagues and I just
that's the same week wasn't same day but
was the same week that I was
contemplating like I'm going to go join
a volleyball league by myself because I
know Mariah would go with me to support
me so at least I can have someone there
for support she wouldn't play or maybe I
could talk her into it either way I was
gonna go join it by myself and meet
other people who who play volleyball
right and I'm sure that if I'm positive
if the dodgeball league didn't come
along I would have absolutely have done
that and I guarantee you I'd have some
new friends by the end of the summer
yeah definitely definitely all right
Jordan I'd love to send you a copy of
our book minimalism live a meaningful
life I know I read that brief excerpt
and I I kind of got lost on the I went
off on another tangent but in there we
talked about the three ways to create
better relationships find new relation
new relationships transform your current
relationships or change who you are now
instead of trying to change other people
maybe it's just and I don't mean like
become someone who you're not yeah be
yourself be but a become a better
version of yourself right all right way
to saying it more more more filled with
integrity and honesty and a vitality for
life
and that attracts often the people that
you want to attract but there's
there's an entire chapter about
evaluating your current relationships
changing who you are and then also
transforming your current relationships
and will send you a copy of that Shawn
if you could reach out to Jordan and
send her a copy
maybe the audiobook of that if you like
our podcast you'll definitely like the
audiobook version of minimalism live a
meaningful life or if she wants the
block book version or the eBook version
we're happy to send you those as well
our next question is from Kayla in
Kansas City I'm a big introvert I often
feel like I'm pressured to spread my
social energy too thin and I can't reach
the close genuine relationships I want
how do I remain polite and kind to the
mass of acquaintances while setting
aside more time for the people who
really add value to my life also it
seems like everyone is expected to have
hundreds of Facebook friends do you
think I should minimize my friends list
to just a few people how would I go
about doing that and handle any
potential backlash dude that is so funny
man I was this was last year when we
were in Ohio I was having lunch I'm
alone I won't name names to protect the
innocent but someone had brought another
friend to lunch to have lunch with me
Mariah and they were like yeah I can
tell this is right before I cancel
Facebook they're like yeah I could tell
uh I could tell you were you're getting
more popular because of the Facebook
Likes and the friends that you have on
Facebook and I just cringed I was like
that's your measurement of like how
popular someone is like I it was it was
actually one of the things that made me
even think like why am I even on
Facebook like this is it's a status
symbol at this point yeah and I feel so
bad for free Kayla here who feels like
she has to have some type of some amount
of you know curated list of friends on
Facebook just to fit in yeah like that
is so unfortunate well we have over a
million followers on social media we do
I don't feel any how my god that is are
you serious
I don't feel any happier so many I do
feel happier right now
I'm just kidding well the funny thing is
like as soon as you get to a million you
you'll see the people with ten million
or you're like yeah we have a million
but I don't have a million on Twitter
and and in fact we have a friend I will
call him out because I love him and I
put Instagram back on my phone this
weekend because it was Ella's birth
birthday you can follow her on Twitter
she's at Ellis and which she's happy
because she has over 2,000 Twitter
followers and she says if she still
believed you the craziest thing or does
she still not believe you she wants me
she doesn't really understand what
Twitter is but she wants we had to read
her she's a narcissist total narcissist
she wants me to read her tweets to her
sometimes yeah Josh read my tweets
anyway our friend Josh he was the
filmmaker and he lives in Melbourne
mm-hmm Melbourne Australia yes he he he
posted something said he said thanks to
everyone that's listened to our new
podcast is called the daily talk show so
shout out to just Josh Jansen of the
daily talk show podcast since we
launched back in January Tommy his
co-host and I have set little goals
throughout and they it was to reach
5,000 downloads for the month we're
nearly there if you haven't listened yet
I love for you to check it out even
share it with a friend and I said
congratulations but what if the goal was
to produce meaningful creations rather
than hit an arbitrary metric call him
out on on social media of course I did
Wow I'm a good friend or good
acquaintance maybe but but I think the
thing is like and and and I think people
like you hold me accountable in ways
like that as well if I were to come to
you and say Ryan we've got to hit you
know 5 million podcast downloads this
month you did you'd be like that's the
goal that's really where you want to end
up and in fact there was a project we
were working on not that long ago where
someone said hey we we had we had
really well creatively on and we felt
really good about it and we got on this
conference call and they're like well we
want to we want to do even better and
and I'm like well what what's your
outcome here and you're like well we
want to sell a [ __ ] ton of units and you
just like I could tell you were pissed
and you're like hey that's a really
shitty business plan and and I think
that's a true like that the truth with
us like maybe we look at ourselves not
as a business plan but as a individual
plan as a how can I be my most congruent
self and that congroo itself has nothing
to do with the metrics I achieve yeah
last week on the PostScript episode you
and I talked about raising your
standards and lowering your expectations
and I won't rehash the whole thing if
you're a patreon supporter you can go
check out the the PostScript episode but
but really I think that's important for
us as individuals these are expectations
mmm hitting X number of downloads having
X number of likes or followers a bla bla
bla bla bla bla bla and they might be
metrics that are indicators sometimes of
what you're doing right or wrong but
when they become the primary driver it's
like that's like we're making money the
primary driver it starts to dilute what
is actually meaningful and our yeah it
goes from meaningful creations to more
content driven yeah content generation
and you know God man it I'm trying to
think uh I don't know Kanye West or Kim
Kardashian or you know one of those you
know very voice Turris loud people who
most people don't want to be yeah but
but they've got more likes they've got
more Twitter followers than me yeah I
wouldn't never trade lives with any of
those people right and I guess it just
goes to show how bad of a metric looking
at looking at likes looking at our
friends list trying to trying to create
content pushing stuff out on social
media
just for the purpose of generating likes
and for generating attention I mean
maybe maybe you're getting the right to
right type of attention on stuff there's
always an exception to the rule but for
sure
for all intents and purposes using
social media like that it is an endless
pursuit right you will never have you
will never have enough likes you'll
never have enough downloads you'll never
have enough content that you can put out
there because it's just going to keep
feeding itself to make it one more right
I mean and there are people who do
really well I think Chris D'Elia does
social media really really well he does
social media well yeah right but it's
it's it's like he uses it as a way to
produce funny creations like he figures
out the medium and the best way to use
that medium as opposed to just like let
me broadcast a bunch of spam he's like
here's the best way for me to use this
and as a consequence he has a lot of fun
yes you know over a million followers on
on whatever platforms right and and
because of that it does go together but
guess what there are plenty of other
people have 17 million followers and all
they do is show their ass in a bikini
right and and so the the number of likes
and so-called engagement isn't the real
engagement real engagement comes from
how deep were willing to go because I
crystal lee is someone where I can
literally find value in a one-minute
clip from him that is hilarious because
it goes deep within that one minute most
people use social media to masturbate in
their own room right there's that that
old essay from which book is that I
think it's an essential yeah please
masturbate it's funny every selfie I see
all it says to me is look at me yeah I
love the selfies words like just hanging
out Memorial Day and it's like what and
if I cleavage right and it's I mean it
the whole purpose of it is look at me
and if you have a look at me attitude
like that is again it's it's a
bottomless pit yeah as opposed to hey I
made this thing and I think you'll find
some value on it that could be a funny
joke in a tweet I mean Twitter is
hilarious if you have there are Twitter
comedians they can't do the staged
comedian thing but they write these
one-liners that I just have me rolling I
mean they're great and so they use the
platform in a way that is appropriate
for communicating what they want to
communicate and so back to Kayla's
question here I mean she talks about
feeling this pressure right especially
as an introvert so I wanna talk about a
few things we alluded to the three the
three different concentric circles of
relationships the primary relationship
secondary and then the tertiary
relationships or the peripheral
relationships and so I found that for me
the right equation as an introvert and I
think the difference we mean you this is
a great example here because I'm extreme
introvert you're extreme extrovert I
think the difference between the two of
us we both have small relatively small
between around five people on our
primary circle you might have a couple
more people than me and in your primary
circle primary relationship is gonna be
a small group of people right around
that the secondary relationships I have
very few and you have a lot of secondary
relationships good friends people you
love and care about and will stay at
your house and and they can definitely
rely on you all the time to hang out
whatever right yeah and then on that
tertiary level the the third level I
feel like we both have a lot of sort of
acquaintances and and and friends who
are on that outer level that maybe we
don't see all the time but we still
people we care about in love we just
don't allocate a lot of time to them
right in fact you and I went to the
comedy store the other night with and I
just sent out a text people know I don't
ask people to go out very often and so I
sent out a text to 14 friends mm-hmm and
who were in that that that group of
people right yeah and 12 of them showed
up yeah because they know I've hey if
Josh is asking he barely ever asked to
go out because I don't go out very much
yes and so I am going to show up
and it's not because I'm some great guys
because they know if I'm if I'm going
out it's one of the rare times that
we're going spend time together
and I guess what I'm trying to
communicate here is just because you
don't see someone every day or every
week as an introvert doesn't mean there
aren't your good friend we just had
breakfast yesterday with our friend
Jason Zook was a Zuk Zuk Zuk so or is it
headsets.com our friend Jason he used to
sell his last name every year to a
company as like this weird hilarious
when we met him he was Jason surfer up
yeah Jason surfer app name is Jason
headsets.com
and now he's Jason hook and which is an
old family name that he just sort of
stole from a grandpa I loved he still
doesn't have his original last name yeah
yeah and Way has a whole back story
behind that you could find him on
Twitter I think he still had Jason does
stuff right yeah and he's really good do
but I hadn't seen him in a couple years
but I still consider him a friend I know
if I needed something he'd be there he's
a person who's in that periphery of my
life because I don't see him every week
or even every month but I also know that
I can sit down and have a meaningful
conversation with him because we do have
similar values and we do have somewhat
similar interests and we're in similar
spaces and now we're in a similar
geography we didn't use so he lives in
like down in San Diego and we live up
here in Los Angeles on Southern
California geography so that will enable
us to actually spend more time together
now and we'll have a closer relationship
because of it right and so just because
you don't see someone every week or
every month doesn't mean that the
relationship can't be meaningful when
you do hang out you hang out once a year
you make that interaction as meaningful
as possible you don't have your phone
out you you don't talk about the weather
you you're able to dive in into these
non obligatory conversations you're
there because you want to be there yeah
absolutely
man you know I would tell you Kayla
you've got to get better at saying no to
be honest with your friends and to look
at them in a genuine in a genuine way
and say no I
not hang out with you I have to go have
my alone time the Comedy Store is a
great example so Josh invites all of us
out there's a certain point where I look
where I look up and Josh is gone him and
Becks left I didn't get a goodbye didn't
get a tap on the shoulder but that's
okay it was like I know that's Josh's mo
that's what he does that's that's that's
something that I support him in doing
that's what you need to do in order to
get your alone time to whatever it is in
fact because we're such good friends
dude I don't even have to ask why yeah
it's like I know that that's what you
got to do so you know it do I get
offended no yeah in in what I'm trying
to say Kayla is that you're your good
friends even your good and quit your
good acquaintances if you're being
honest with them if you're being genuine
they're not going to get offended by you
saying no I cannot hang out with you I
have to have my alone time and if they
don't understand then [ __ ] them they're
not your friends they're not good
friends they're not good acquaintances
so maybe Kayla use this has a really
good way to filter out who your who your
frenemies are and yeah this this is this
is something that I I have just now been
able to grasp like over the last five or
six years and that sees back to that
that's me being the the that being my
authentic self and and with Becks is
difficult for her because she's been
acculturated for many many years she
grew up in Minnesota and you heard of
the Minnesota goodbye it's like people
like they just constantly say goodbye
goodbye it's like a 25 minute goodbye
really they walk you out to the door and
then they walk you outside the door onto
the porch and if the opposite of that is
the Irish goodbye right that's what I do
I leave yeah and I just exit I just in
and guess what no one actually cares and
that's the thing like and so the
pressure that you feel Kayla 99% of that
pressure that you feel is internal yes
it's her putting it on herself
yeah and back to what Ryan said the
other one person if someone is putting
some unnecessary pressure on you that's
on them that's not even on you anyway so
realize that most that pressure is all
yours and I heard this term recently on
Josh Zepps
caste he has a podcast called we the
people live and sort of a debate show
and a conversation slash debate show and
this term came up we've all heard a FOMO
the fear of missing out and I think
that's what that's what Kayla's talking
about right now especially with the
having hundreds of Facebook friends and
in fact I deleted my LinkedIn account
this week Ryan and you just now deleted
that do you have one oh well I didn't
real and like I got some like update
policy update from them you know your
policy or privacy policy is chair
whatever and I'm like why do I still
have a LinkedIn account and and then I'm
like I never use this is stupid I'm
going to delete it and now I went in to
delete it and I saw all these unread
messages from like Matt ridin Bakken and
Chris Herren juror and and like people
hadn't talked to in years people I like
but I'm like I haven't talked to them in
and I'm like all of a sudden I'm I can't
delete this there's all these messages
in here and so all of a sudden I had the
fear of missing out but really it was
this term I hear not the FOMO but the
funk fo in see the fear of not
connecting alright I'll go with it
well here's the thing like oh I got in
there and I'm like all but I have to be
connected to these people so I can't
delete my my LinkedIn account what are
you doing that's so weird as an
introvert you you have funk yeah but
it's it's really not it's not even the
fear of not connecting it's the fear of
potentially not connecting right yeah
like if if someone near Rivini is it is
it if someone needs to get ahold of you
or if you need to get ahold of someone
or is it both I think it's neither in a
weird ways I found that when I deleted
Facebook it was like there were certain
people there's still are certain people
I only had access to them on Facebook
and I've wanted to like reactivate
reactivate my Facebook account so I
could send the messages mm-hmm and say
hey here's my cellphone number in case
you ever want to connect but what I
realize is that these people will find
me one way or the other and and but but
I guess I'm just trying to relate here
because
yeah there was a certain point where I'm
like oh [ __ ] like that person that I
really enjoyed diem and back and forth
with that was only on Facebook right but
again like we have found other ways to
connect so for you what is it is it's
it's the fear of when I just saw it in
there I'm like oh these are messages
from people that I that were once
definitely in one of those circles for
me in fact many of them were like close
to primary I spent more time with these
many of them just LinkedIn so it's
coworkers mostly right I spent 40 hours
a week with some of these people or 60
hours a week you know I spent a ton of
time with with with these people and now
it was sudden I don't and and part of it
is is not even the FOMO or the fear of
not connecting it's just the nostalgia
and I think nostalgia is dangerous
because it it relives a past that didn't
exist the past is not as rosy you know I
know we want to think that everything
was great in the 1950s but it wasn't I
mean this is a we've never lived in a
better time than right now and it will
continue to get better and by living in
a nostalgic world it pretends that
things were better and it doesn't give
credit to how good things are right now
and so I just deleted it and guess what
I lived past it so I think one of the
things that the caila can do here she
can unfollow the quote friends that she
doesn't want to follow it and I won't
create any tension whatsoever for her
you don't have to unfriend them or
defriend them or whatever term people
are using now or you can do it Ryan
didn't just delete your whole account
and you might be happier because of it
and you leave it for a while I'm sure
you can always bring it back in if they
wouldn't always take you back Kayla yeah
they're not gonna kick you out of the
Facebook club they will they would love
yeah they would love to have you back in
the club I mean I think the last thing
that just remember here is that
introverts probably need fewer secondary
relationships so Ryan said say get good
at saying no or this say yes to the
right things like the Comedy Store night
that it's a great strategy for me so we
show off about our early to get in line
there and so I get to spend 30 minutes
to 45 minutes with this group of 12
friends as they slowly trickle in
but then we're inside and I no longer
have to interact with them one-on-one
but we still get to share this
experience together we're texting about
it the next day who was your favorite
all mine was this one and and but I
don't have to spend four hours with
people having just a constant non-stop
conversation we get the connection we
get to have the interaction and
experience together mm-hmm but we don't
have to constantly interact so create
the the right experiences with those
folks as well yeah Kayla loves in you
copy of our book essential there's a the
ninth chapter in there is a chapter
about relationships and they're a bunch
of different essays about different
types of relationships what we can do to
improve our relationship so essential is
an essay collection with 150 different
essays and those essays range on
different times 12 different topics so
everything from minimalism and stuff to
relationships and mindfulness and
everything in between so I hope you find
value in that book Shaun if you could
reach out the tequila give her the
audiobook version of that or maybe the
book or the eBook version if she would
like all right we'd love to hear what
y'all have to say so if you have a
comment or a tip about acquaintances
about relationships about the people in
your life including advice for any of
our callers today then leave us a
voicemail for 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 you can
also email a voice memo right from your
phone to podcast at the minimalists comm
where our favorite comments and tips on
a future episode and stay tuned to the
end of this episode we'll have our
favorite comments and tips at the end of
this episode as well Ryan what time is a
you know what time it is it's time for
the minimalists lightning round where we
answer questions from social media
indeed we do we're on Twitter Facebook
and Instagram at the minimalists join
over a million people good good
or don't you don't have to follow us and
or unfollow us if we're not adding value
amen to that
during the lightning round this were
Ryan and I each do our best to answer
every question with just a short
shareable less than 140 character
response we also put the text to these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answer is
on social media if you'd like and now
you can find all of our pithy answers in
one place thank you to jessica lynn
williams our wonderful social media
manager she
collected all of our minimal Maxim's
over at minimal Maxim's dot-com alright
our first question is from Daisy what's
the value of having acquaintances who
are responsible with their money I'll
have a short answer for you and I think
I'll just leave it at this short answer
here right mm-hmm responsibility is
contagious and so whether that's with
money or not I I think your answer leads
into a better discussion point thanks
man you know
I'm when I read this question I'm
confused on how it's not valuable yeah
like how would it yeah maybe it's like
having having the people around you to
have an example of what not to do yeah
surround yourself with the examples of
what not to do with your life yeah I
wouldn't do that now here's why your
friends reflect you and you reflect them
yeah it's a it's a mirror right I mean
and you become better in time with with
when I said responsibility is contagious
I think the office is also true
irresponsibility I did a lot of
irresponsible [ __ ] during my teenage
years a lot of things that could have
put me in jail for well probably if I
did my as an adult for a rather long
time and it's because I spent some time
with some people who were just as
irresponsible as me and that
irresponsibility breeds irresponsibility
and it was a vicious downward spiral
till we reached this unhealthy nadir of
discontent and unhappiness and stewing
in our continual losses yeah I totally
agree all right our next question is
from Tracy how can you get past the
stage of having acquaintances and turn
them into meaningful and fruitful
friendships well my short answer is you
get more when you give more and so I
think when we approach a relationship it
doesn't have to be an acquaintance it
could be a person who's on the Outer
Banks
of your peripheral relationships the
peripheral tear right and so you have
the people who are burying that barely
in that tertiary circle there on the
outer banks of that there the person at
the coffee shop across the street that I
went to to get coffee this morning
and his name is Joshua and although
people call him Tito and which I wish I
had some quotes to say like that like
what's your name Joshua but people call
me Tito let's say oh you money than my
name is Chris but uh the the the thing
that I when I was talking him across the
street like even I don't know him really
right but I want to give to that short
interaction that I have right well I'm
how am I gonna make the best of this
interaction so that it's not just
transactional but so that I leave here
feeling good about myself that in create
changes my state changes his state he's
feeling good he remembers my name next
time I remember his name so I going in
the coffee shop hey do you want the
usual or whatever and all of a sudden
we're creating this acquaintance ship
that over time who knows I think my good
friend Nate green from Nate green org he
he was just on our friend Matthew Ella's
podcast recently I love how all of all
of our friends have websites you can
visit I think everyone will have a
website within the next five years 2008
called they want their prediction back
I mean podcast sean has a website I'm
sorry yes a good friend Nate green yeah
he we met each other at a coffee shop we
were at Zoo Town brew in Missoula
Montana I was just hanging out and he
came up and said hey man I really
appreciate what you're doing I don't
want to bother you
here's a gift card I think what you're
doing really adds value to people's
lives this is a good way for me to add
value to your life and that was it he
didn't say anything else he didn't say
here's my Twitter handle or something
but then I saw him in the coffee shop
again like a month later I'm like hey
man thanks again for that gift card
let's sit down and talk and we just had
a good conversation like I had there it
was good timing like cuz most time I'm
in a coffee shop I don't have time to
sit down talk but I had 15
I had to sat down with him and I'm like
hey you got a few minutes let's just
chat and we've become really good
friends he became he was he was staying
at your place last week
yeah he's the first person to ever stay
at my place here in California yeah him
and his uh yeah him and his girl
Rochelle yeah yeah and so that they were
here and they stayed for an entire week
and we had a really great week together
we shared gratitude practices together
like we had a really great week we went
to vote a spa together like we hit we
had all of these voters like the Russian
bath house
four people were listening to this and
and we just had a really good time
together but it started off just because
he gave something without any
expectation of anything in return he
didn't say I'm going to give him this
$20 gift card because one day I'm gonna
need a place the same for six days and
Los Angeles California no it doesn't
work that way you're gonna give a bunch
and you won't always get back it's not
it's not a reciprocal relationship you
give what you can and then you get what
you need what a great example of raising
your standards and lowering your
expectations a man absolutely about you
Ryan for me my short answer is this the
more values and beliefs two people share
the more fruitful the relationship you
know just going back to that beliefs
part I think that yes we absolutely need
to have we need to be hanging out with
people who who share different beliefs
for for me and what I've learned the
hard ways it's not healthy to just be
around people with the same beliefs
because personally I start to get
disconnected from the real world yeah I
started to get disconnected from how you
know maybe there's this group of 8
million people or nine million people
who believe the same thing well there
are you know 7 billion people on the
planet I started to get disconnected and
and start to become apathetic to to
people's beliefs and a lot of the time
beliefs have values associated with them
yeah and so and it's hard to uncouple
them but it's possible to uncouple them
yeah absolutely I will say though that
like you and Becks for example if you
guys had very different beliefs let's
say Bex was a hardcore Christian you
probably wouldn't be with her not not
for any other reason then those are very
different
radical beliefs it will require you to
support something that you necessarily
you know don't go out of your way to
support yeah but I have a lot of friends
who are hardcore Christian absolutely
you wouldn't marry him though right you
wouldn't live with them and but but yeah
that's true but I I have I would argue
that I have at least one or two primary
relationships for people who are are
fundamentalist Christian yeah absolutely
absolutely I think what I'm trying to
get at is is that I I don't want to take
beliefs off the table when it comes to
relationships right I don't want it to
just be this inclusive thing that's on
the table yeah what I'm trying to get
out with this comment is that when you
the more values you share with someone
the more beliefs that you share with
someone that relationship that you have
with that person or people it's going to
be a much more fruitful relationship
yeah I Altima comes down to what we mean
by beliefs I agree with you that beliefs
the world is round the belief that you
should treat people well yeah sure yeah
yeah yeah to me that a lot of those are
values meaning that the world is round
thing like yeah again III I don't have
someone who believes the earth is flat
and truly believes that as a mentally
ill person and and so i yeah i'm not i
hope they can get the help that they
need and i'm happy to help facilitate
that help but if someone actually
believes that then yeah that they're
probably not going to be in my inner
circle unless they have some sort of
mental illness and then I'm gonna trying
to get them the help they need sure sure
absolutely but but with respect to I
mean I think about my good friend we're
gonna see in a couple months we went to
high school together
and he is a pastor right and we I mean
we I call him up you know once a month
I'm like hey you still believe in God
mm-hmm he's like yeah I'm like all right
talk to you later and like it's just
it's a where we have an understanding of
each other
because and we're able to joke with each
other like that in a way you know but
you still go in the hell and I'm like
yeah I guess I am like like but just in
a way that is that it's joking but we
also have some of the most profound
questions or conversations because
we have different beliefs and we're not
trying to convince the other person so
much as we're trying to strengthen or
improve our points and sometimes
improving my point means totally
changing my point of view altogether
sometimes and if we have relation
relationships who can be open to other
beliefs then maybe that's the the
ultimate good relationship being open to
changing your belief as as you're
presented with with new information yeah
all right oh one more question we have
here I think we could do a whole episode
on frenemies Ryan I've wanted to do an
episode on front of me so invar asks how
do I break up with frenemies now I've
always wanted to do a whole episode
about frenemies and now we kind of get
to because if you want to hear our
answer to inverse question about how do
you break up with frenemies well then
you can tune in to this week's
PostScript episode over at the
minimalist private podcast which is
available exclusively to our patreon
supporters that's why it is a private
podcast so I'm sorry that I'm laughing
anything here dude but you've got the
definite you stop don't don't I don't
run it I'm not gonna learn I'm teasing
it okay you have the you have written
the definition of frenemy here I'm not
gonna read the definition aloud but I'm
just wondering is this something you
found in the dictionary or the urban
dictionary because personally that urban
dictionary is what I use all the time
this is an actual definition from a
dictionary but then I expand on the
definition a little bit so if you want
to support our show and keep this
podcast 100% advertisement free then
head on over to the minimalists comm
slash support in addition to our weekly
PostScript episodes
the minimalist private podcasts feed
includes our monthly ask the minimalist
anything episodes we just did our tenth
one of those we have ten of the we have
51 or 52 private podcasts out there now
and you can you can access the whole
back catalogue of private podcasts
including Alton asked the minimalist
anything episodes also unreleased
recordings of our live events we just
put up I think my favorite event of the
Australian tour the Sydney event that
was a really good one we got the
Melbourne event coming really soon as
well that was Ryan's favorite event
of the Australian tour so that's going
out there we got a bunch of other live
events coming and we already put up a
bunch of our other live events in the
private podcast stream as well and of
course the the weekly postscript
episodes and you get the entire back
catalogue of past private episodes once
you become a supporter you'll receive a
personal link to our private podcast
feed so that it plays in whatever
podcast app you use right next to the
podcast that you're listening to right
now and as a patreon supporter you also
receive access to our monthly live
stream videos as well as as first access
to tickets to all of our live events
before those a ticket those tickets are
available to the general public so Ryan
and I are about to announce the simply
southern tour we're going on a three
city tour in Kentucky and Alabama and
Tennessee and if you want access to
those tickets before they go on sale to
the general public then become a patreon
supporter and you can get the best seats
in the house really looking forward to
those events man so yeah just for those
listening is this the first time we're
talking about it I we've teased it a
little bit last week so they're gonna go
on sale to the general public June 8th
it's called the simply southern tool did
we tease it in the podcast for the
patreon the private cast then it was a
regular pot yeah regular last week's
intentional episode we teased a little
bit but the pre-sale for patreon
Sephora's goes on sale June 6 2018 you
can find all the details and good stuff
over at the minimalists com slash
support and here is a snippet from this
week's PostScript episode
[Music]
as soon as someone starts gossiping to
me that throws up a huge red flag yeah
anyone in my life who starts gossiping
because if someone gossips to you they
will gossip about you absolutely as soon
as you're not there they're talking
about you and so if you're that person
if you're if you're listening to this
and you're that person who gossips about
other people when they're not there then
then you're gossiping to people that
then realize people see you and they
realize you can't be you're not a
trusted person you're not a confidant
you may feel like you are but you're
actually not in these scenarios all
right and we're back and if you want to
hear that full conversation you can
become a patron over at the minimalists
com
okay now it's time for our added value
portion of the show so Bo Ryan and I
both talked about something that has
added value to our lives
recently I have three things Ryan I'm
I've been purging my lists cuz I just
had this huge list I've been trying to
get rid of some of them this new album
just came out and it's called run two
waters by Justin azúcar are you familiar
with his music he had a big hit single I
think back in yachties it kind of
reminds me of like a really soft version
of Charlie Mars's music member Charlie
Mars yeah it's it's like one of those
albums you just want to put on and like
relax on a Sunday
it's singer-songwriter and his voice is
like super melodic and calm and and I
put it on and Ella was like humming
along to it in the car we were driving
down to Disneyland for her birthday she
absolutely loved it and except she
requested another album I asked her what
she wanted to hear on so we went to
Disneyland a day before her birthday and
on her birthday morning I asked her what
she wanted to hear and I said I want to
hear push a tee I haven't checked out
that oh yeah that's called Daytona it
only has 7 songs on it it is a great
album except he is in a feud with Drake
right now and Drake just roasted him
over the weekend man I can't keep up
with these hip-hop feuds oh it's so
excited by the time we're recording this
they like Pusha T has not responded he
put out what might be a classic album
the the beats on it were so all
production is done by Kanye West and
it's like this ultra minimalist
soundscape - what is some fairly absurd
overindulgent consumerist rap but if you
can set that aside for a moment his
talent level is it's superb and so like
- recommendations they're just in the
Zuka and pusha t couldn't be be any any
different but they're both great albums
and I've had this one on my list for a
while ID so it's it's past due have you
heard of the show halt and catch fire
mm-hmm we're on tour 2014 the first
season came out so I just finished the
fourth and final season of it a few
months ago it takes place in the 80s
during this sort of tech boom it starts
to the early 80s and the season ends or
the four season and sort of like the
late 80s and maybe even early 90s this
is fiction right it is but it's based
very loosely on like compact and Steve
Jobs and like it so kind of takes these
like famous like people who are you know
at the time they were cutting edge
technology and stories we hear about and
kind of introduce them a little bit yeah
but it fictional eise's them so it's not
the actual Steve Jobs but it's a
character from based on the life of and
and it's a character based on the life
of McAfee before he went crazy and
started well I don't I don't know what
he did I mean he's really into like wow
I was probably not appropriate Oh Google
it later no I don't don't want Google
Image Search yeah that's for sure anyway
you know how many people just pause this
[Laughter]
have you seen two girls one cop Ryan de
McAfee directed I think he was like
recreating it oh my god it was like one
crazy guy one cup anyway
he
anyway the show has nothing to do with
any of that
halt and catch fire we were on tour in
2014 and like I was looking for
something to watch and so I for whatever
reason like turned on I think it's on
AMC or A&E or one of these channels that
we were on in a hotel room and the show
from the 1980s was on and I'm like I
don't remember the show being on the
eighties that's how true to the like it
looked so 1980s but like really high
calling how did they get this high
quality camera work in the 80s
it looked so spot-on 1981 saying like
set design wardrobe is like you know in
1980s yeah the atmospherics the
aesthetics of the show were amazing but
also the plot and the the the character
relationships in this show so what I
would encourage you do not watch the
fourth season like I just finished just
go back and watch the first episode of
the first season see if you like it see
if it attracts you if it feels so
genuine to 1980 then then if you look
for something to watch then it's a it's
a show that I found immensely valuable
and I connected with a lot of the
characters emotionally and aesthetically
as well I found that the show was just
so well done that I I got really
involved with it by the end of it you
know I've been looking for different and
most of them are nonfiction tight like
Doc Oh serious type things that that end
up being like this sometimes you can
find some series that that have only a
season or two but what I'm getting at is
like that's that's what I've been after
watching wild wild country was six
episodes it was about 50 minutes long
each it you know the most I could pinch
in one day with six hours it wasn't
spewing into the next day I didn't watch
them all at once but my point is is that
there's there's a really nice mini taco
series called evil genius I heard about
this I haven't seen it though dude it is
it's good man um there was there was I'd
never heard of this this this this
instance in the news but there was this
case where like this dude walked into a
bank he had a bomb
strapped around his neck and he hands
the teller know and it basically says
you know I want money essentially but
the whole thing is like as the cops
catch this guy because eventually I mean
you know you got a big bomb around your
neck you're robbing a bank cops are
probably gonna find you then have like
the Flavor Flav clock on it no so so um
as this dude is being apprehended by the
police he would he's basically yelling
out like I like I've been kidnapped
this bomb has been put around my neck
and if I don't get if I don't follow
these instructions this bomb is going to
go off I'm just gonna leave it there ah
so this is essentially a deep dive into
what the hell transpired over over this
hole where do you find a case it's on
Netflix all right and it is yeah it is
uh
it's I think it's I want to say it's
four episodes but anyway it's it's like
yeah it's something that's totally
palatable like you know it won't you
won't waste weekends watching this and
it is it is a truly like just
interesting story I'm looking for a good
documentary so I'm gonna check that out
yeah evil genius evil genius all right
let's check it out all right it's time
to move on the right here right now so
we talked about what's going on in the
lives of the minimalist we've got a lot
of good creations hopefully outstanding
creations coming up really soon first
off something called living room
conversations every day in June 2018 on
the minimalists YouTube channel so go to
youtube.com slash the minimalist I'm
gonna be answering a question every day
in June and Ryan has agreed to be a
special guest on living room
conversational we're going to do this
video series for at least 30 days every
one day every day in June answering your
questions if you do have questions you
can submit them over on youtube.com
slash the minimalists as well speaking
of creating videos we're going to be
creating a lot more video work so we're
going to be hiring a filmmaker really
soon to create a video version of the
podcast and other video creations June
15th is we're going to put the job
posting for that up on the website that
minimalists com
or you can just subscribe to our email
list over at them and
lists and you'll get that right there in
your inbox as well as all of the show
notes for these podcasts as well and any
new essays that we write including the
new essay that I just put out called
small losses I'm gonna read this really
quickly small losses we all agree it's
important to celebrate the tiny
victories you worked out yesterday you
ate a healthy lunch today you'll phone
someone you love tomorrow her a tiny
triumphs are worthy of lowercase praise
we needn't wait until the full body
transformation the championship title
the next major accomplishment to
acknowledge our progress in fact wait
until something miraculous happens
marginalizes are small wins which leads
to fewer favorable results going forward
until eventually the whole thing
collapses collapses under the weight of
a million micro indiscretions true that
buzzer beating 3-pointer might have won
the big game but so did every practice
session and every scrimmage game and
every four foot bank shot in the first
quarter
flip the coin though and we realize the
opposite is also true
it's equally important to acknowledge
our small losses you skip the gym this
morning
you ate leftover chocolate cake this
afternoon I know I did that
damn it with Ella's birthday we had some
leftover chocolate cake that night this
is why I don't keep keep cake in the
house Josh yeah I don't either but Ella
does I threw the rest out next morning
LS that a trash can if she was like what
why'd you throw out the chocolate cake
I'm like it will spoil eventually what
spoil shut up you threw a cake happy
birthday you aged leftover chocolate
cake this afternoon
you'll ignore your spouse when he's
talking tonight shame we must reflect on
our minut infractions and miss behaviors
with a lowercase scorn no we needn't
dwell on our missteps we need only
concede that we tripped up a bit and
then carry that lesson forward you see
we are all amalgams of our small wins
and our small losses
therefore each giant victory is a
product of every small loss we avoid
what matters then is what we do when our
most recent between our most recent loss
and the most small mote in the next
small victory you can find that essay
it's the minimalists comm slash losses
and if you want any new essays in your
inbox just shot sign up for our email
list over at the minimalists comm will
never send you any spam ever because
that stuff is gross you know that sa man
it's it's really because you know we
vote we've all heard you know learn from
your failures right and when people
think about learning from your failures
it is typically these big failures like
oh like I yeah I lost the game or I
didn't get my book accepted you know by
a publisher I mean there are these big
failures yeah but yeah man that essay is
like it's a nice reminder of like learn
from your mistakes like all of your
mistakes so you don't have to yeah you
don't have to wait for the big failure
right because by then it's really hard
to course-correct
it's way easier of course crack you're
like you know I screwed up and I had a
little bit of leftover chocolate cake so
I'm gonna throw this out I'm
acknowledging that loss so I don't have
a big loss gained all of my 80 pounds
back from a decade ago right right it's
just not gonna happen
and so acknowledge that small loss now
so you don't have to acknowledge this
the huge loss later
what else is going o also on patreon
right now the Sydney event I already
mentioned that all ten ask the
minimalist anything episodes we got the
videos and the the audio version of
those as well are posted on the
minimalist private podcast simply
southern tour we're headed to Birmingham
Louisville and Nashville so we're gonna
be in Alabama Kentucky and Tennessee
we're gonna have three special guests
and I hope they be able to nassos guess
next week or actually next week on the
on the well on the podcast but also this
week on the website so you'll see those
over there on the website if you want
access to the early tickets become a
patreon supporter or they go on sale to
the general public on June 8th now this
gonna be Ryan and I getting up a giving
a talk you're gonna join us for a night
of less we're gonna bring a special
guest on to the podcast we're talking
about minimalism decluttering we're also
gonna talk about finances and family and
budgeting and I know one of the biggest
hardest things to talk about with people
that we care about is money right and so
we're gonna have these three events
where we talk about money and how that
how we can improve our relationship with
money so we can reprove the
relationships in our lives I'm really
looking forward to it man yeah this is
not the this isn't the less is now tour
there isn't a note no talk it is it's us
bringing a friend on stage to talk about
some really important things
yeah and we're also gonna have another
friend there Canyon City who you heard
on our hobbies podcast he's gonna open
up all three events with some beautiful
music so you can join us for that as
well
one last thing I am teaching a writing
class twice a year I do a two hour
writing workshop it's called how to
write better and it's an online writing
class limited the 300 people and those
tend to sell out you can find all the
details that over at the minimalists
comm slash workshop I want to try to
help you improve your writing whether
it's improving your business emails or
if you want to write that first book or
maybe you want to start a blog or write
better blog posts or maybe you just want
to write better text messages I don't
know but I believe the rising tide lifts
all boats and so I tweeze out the most
important ingredients from my four week
writing class over at how to write
better org and spend these two hours
with you talking about composition
editing publishing and developing a good
writing habit to improve your overall
writing I want to help you write better
and I think I can do that in just those
two short hours I also answer some
questions we do a bit of a writing QA at
the end of that so you can Jim join me
June 24th details over at the
minimalists comm slash workshop Ryan you
got anything else for us yeah man here
are some voicemail comments and tips
from our listeners
hi my name is Kelly I've actually been
binge listening to Sameer episodes on my
long commute to work and had a couple of
low-cost solutions based on your
episodes on school and food so for
people who are considering going to
college or graduate school and aren't
sure if it's right for them there is
actually an online company called
Coursera they offer courses and for some
of them you can actually earn a
certification they offer online courses
that are offered by universities and
taught by university professors and all
different kinds of topics right now I'm
actually taking the content management
course through Northwestern University
and the subscription to do this is $50 a
month so you can take the courses at
your own pace finish at your own pace
and at the end if you decide to finish
you get a certificate if you don't
decide to finish you can unsubscribe so
it's a low-cost way to kind of dabble in
higher education if you're trying to
figure out if school is something that
you're interested in and since they
offer classes on all kinds of topics you
can also dabble in different areas or
majors to see where your interests may
lie in regards to the food episode I
know there some people express concerns
about wanting to eat organic but the
cost was a deterrent for them there is
actually a new company called imperfect
produce and what they do is they offer
organic and/or non-organic options for
delivery actually they take the produce
that otherwise would have been sent to a
landfill or not bought by grocery stores
just because the produce might be a
little large it might be a little small
it might not look what we call perfect
and those are often the groceries that
are overlooked at the grocery store so
what they do is
take that produce and they actually sell
it you can customize your box online and
decide what you want whether it's every
week or every other week and the box
actually shows up at your door it's a
company that's growing so they're don't
offer for all cities but they're slowly
expanding it's very inexpensive and you
get organic produce delivered straight
to you for a cost that would be much
lower than buying it at say Whole Foods
or an agro Surry store that has
expensive items hi guys
my name is Maria I'm from Moscow Russia
I have a bipolar disorder and most of
the time I don't have a lot of energy so
stuff kind of piles up whenever I do
have it I start decluttering and I don't
just get rid of things I don't need or
like or haven't used in a while I also
ask myself does this thing makes me feel
better about myself or worse for example
I'm good at cooking and since I have to
eat
I cook once a week or so but mostly I
live on take-out and order ends and even
though I always order healthy food and
have a pretty good eating habits I still
feel guilty about not having home-cooked
meals I never wanted to cook in the
first place but having all those cooking
stuff and not using it puts stress on me
it's three times a day struggle so last
month I said to myself okay I don't want
to worry about that anymore it makes me
like myself less so I got rid of most of
my kitchenware and kept only few things
essential to making eggs and coffee I
instantly felt better without all those
pans and pots staring at me every time I
enter my kitchen I don't have that
stress anymore and while I don't
recommend that particular kind of
cleanup I will definitely say to anyone
with bipolar or depression
having only things that you'll like to
use or just look at will make you feel
so much better I know that most of us
think one day I'll get better and I
finish that book or DIY project but
sometimes not doing that is what makes
you closer to getting better so throw it
out find it in your home you don't want
stuff dragging you down hi my name is
Rami I'm from Bunbury in Western
Australia and my tip is for Adam there
what climber that called a few episodes
back he was wondering how to apply
minimalism to rock climbing so Adam I
have really good news for you rock
climbing can be really budget if you
want it to be and I think this could
apply to many extreme sports or any
sports as it is if you want to save
money well if you're just gonna climb
bouldering all you need is a pair of
shoes at your back and maybe a crash mat
you just climb short distances so the
risk of falling is minimal if you still
want to go all the way up you can share
your equipment with a friend and if you
climb you always need to partner with
you unless you're doing free climbing
which are I don't do it I don't really
recommend and so between the two of you
you only need one kit of gear your
climbing gear as well if you take really
good care of it and keep it out or the
weather as much as you can you can keep
it up to ten years if there's no damage
on it now with rock climbing there's a
lot of temptation as well with buying
new gear all the time they always come
up with the latest thing the same for
any other sports really with rock
climbing nothing's changed in the last
50 years
the gear is getting a bit lighter looks
a bit flashier but really if you always
keep in mind that you get your enjoyment
from this
or just from being active at it rather
than buying the latest gadget or the
last tool you'll always think twice
before you buy the next piece of gear
keep in mind never save money if you're
gonna risk yourself always spend extra
dollar if it's gonna keep you safe but
think twice if you're being realistic
with yourself and you're really keeping
yourself safe or you're just buying
another piece of gear I could use flash
and shiny and you another thing with
your shoes you don't have to buy new
shoes every time you wear them out
though heaps of little businesses out
there that will fix your shoes for you
mend them resold them for a fraction of
the price and on the cost around 40
bucks where a brand new pair of shoes
could cost you anywhere from 150 to 200
dollars so you save quite a bit of coin
there thank you for that
stay safe and enjoy your climbing
alright y'all that's it for this episode
if you have a question for the
minimalist give us a call for zero six
two one nine seven eight three nine you
can also email a voice memo right from
your phone to podcast at the minimalists
comm and if you leave here with just one
message we hope it's this love people
and use things because the opposite
never works thanks for listening y'all
we'll see you next time
and minimalists